due to my personal choice to take a
moral stand against
for
medical freedom and personal choice
i will be signing out of service for the
last time today please please please
take care of each other
make sure you all go home at the end of
each day this is my final sign off after
22 years of serving the citizens of the
state of washington i'm being asked to
leave because i am dirty this is the
last time you'll hear me in a state
patrol car
and jansley can kiss my
wow that's a lot of emotion they've
dedicated their careers to public safety
jason rantz is a seattle radio talk show
host jason just first of all your
reaction to that
well i mean in the case of the latter
video you play that's uh
trooper lemay he's been on my show for
several times over the last several
months and i've been following closely
his struggle here these are two people
in these in this case
who are deeply religious they have
religious convictions against this
particular vaccine they're also as you
heard doing it for the sake of personal
freedoms and medical choice when you
look at not just the troopers but any of
the law enforcement officers who are
impacted by this mandate many of them
have told me privately yeah i'm
vaccinated but i don't think it's the
right of the government to require this
as a condition of employment and that's
what we're starting to see a lot of
there's this belief that everyone who's
pushing back is unvaccinated that's just
simply not true that is fascinating and
that is why
i was making such the point about they
just want to know are you or are you not
but then jason i wonder if something
else isn't at play because when i find
out in chicago that they're not going to
foot the bill for the testing after
mandating that you go get something else
a vaccine but they're not going to offer
you it feels like they're negotiating in
bad faith and then they're not going to
give you the time to go get that testing
feels like they're negotiating in bad
faith
like you you don't think that they have
some tax dollars to be able to support
that
it blows my mind
yeah they very clearly have the money to
do that although i'll say in seattle for
example there's no testing option you're
either getting vaccinated or you're
going to be fired and i think that
that's the problem here you're not even
given the option in some of these cases
we were told
over the last 18 months that all of
these folks were heroes they're
frontline workers essentially and
they're protecting us and they're doing
so a great risk to themselves now last
year at this exact time there was zero
percent vaccination right now for
example in seattle and washington in
general there's about 80 percent of the
state vaccinated with at least one shot
they're telling us back then
it was safer than it is now for these
law enforcement officials to do their
jobs that doesn't make sense and it's
not like after they get vaccinated
they're losing all the ppe that they've
been wearing they still have to wear
that too and so nothing has effectively
changed in that regard so when when we
talk about the percentages um the
numbers i don't want to talk about
people as percentages but the numbers of
officers who died of covet in the
country
that is something that people are
looking at just in terms of safety here
but that hasn't persisted necessarily as
high as it was at one point so are maybe
potentially more getting natural
immunity as you said you know officers
who are vaccinated they just don't want
to talk about it
exactly and i think that's really
important to pay attention to it's
certainly true that there have been
officers who have died from covet not
necessarily covert that they caught on
the job which i think is an important
distinction here there's been plenty of
studies including out here in washington
that show ems responders to emergencies
who are dealing with people who in some
cases you're not going to be able to
even wear your own mask depending on
what you're doing with that individual
and it showed a very little if not
insignificant amount of transmission
of cova between patient and ems provider
and vice versa so we have to be honest
about what we're doing here and if we're
talking about
hundreds or thousands of officers across
the country being put out of a job
against serious public health
implications yeah more than 300 in your
area seattle police officers have
retired or quit in just the past year
and they are citing anti-police
sentiment across the country and of
course this comes as shooting incidents
have spiked by 39 percent from the same
period last year you already had a
cauldron
and now just more flame and gasoline on
that
yeah we're in territory we've not been
since the 80s as far as how many
deployable officers we have we're not
right now we're at a stage three
mobilization effort for the seattle
police department which means anyone who
is deployable is uniform ready wow
because if we need to respond to
that detective who right now is maybe
working trying to solve a murder case
we'll end up going and responding to
9-1-1 calls today we expect potentially
depending on what ends up happening with
the final numbers when they get reported
but we're expecting about 60 possibly 70
officers who will not have submitted
their paperwork and who will be
unemployed shortly at a time when i
spoke to the police chief just a couple
weeks ago said we need as many people
hired right now as possible we're about
500 or so shorter than where we need to
be unbelievable real quickly the
politics of this democrat mayor
chicago lori lightfoot i mean do these
leaders realize
that they are leading their own public
into a corner with no one to protect
them from being cornered
i mean if something happens to you in
the city of chicago or seattle
potentially after people leave their
jobs over the fight with these
city councils and mayors
i mean i thought their number one job
was public safety how do they stay in
office
yeah well i mean these are cities that
are run by folks who have been pushing
defund policing i think lori lightfoot
has walked that back pretty
significantly i think mayor jenny durkin
here in seattle has walked it back some
but still council members are leaning
into the defunding and what a better way
to defund the police when you get them
to quit on their own and claim well they
were selfish they didn't want to protect
the public from covet which is of course
a bogus excuse but it's a way to do it
without having to pass any legislation
or any budget cuts 80 percent of the
budget for the seattle police department
is personnel so you lose a few of those
officers you get closer to that 50
percent defunding that they promised
yeah and then they tricked them
by either making the testing nearly
impossible on their shifts and not paid
for or like in your city just don't give
them an alternative at all at all rather
just you know this way or the highway
it's a trick
it's not honest negotiation
jason rantz always great to have you in
focus thank you